Coffee on Tuesday and block six.
I was trying to figure out what I should
do for my next blog,
so I went upstairs and talked to my
neighbors,
told me he's been dying to go to the big
scientology complex on sunset boulevard.
So I said,
perfect
with scientology.
Here it is.
Church of Scientology.
He didn't let us take the camera inside,
so I'll just tell you what happened
next.
We were greeted by a receptionist who
looked like he was 19 years old and
looked us straight in the eye.
Everybody in that building looks you
straight in the eye.
The first thing he did was pushed
forward a piece of paper on what you
were supposed to write,
our first name or last name,
our address,
our phone number,
and the reason why we were coming here,
we said that we were interested in the
religion and that we wanted to know more
about it.
So he suggested that we take the self
guided multimedia tour.
This is an invitation to freedom,
man can save his soul.
So in the back part of the lobbyists,
all these interactive tvs where you can
watch different aspects of scientology
and move your way around and learn all
different types of things.
I got these two sample dvds first the
way to happiness and seconds,
scientology and overview.
There was a booth on scientology ethics.
There was a booth on the evil of
psychiatry.
I've never agreed with psychiatry
ever
before.
I was a scientologist.
I never agreed with psychiatry.
And then when I started studying the
history of psychiatry,
I started realizing more and more why I
didn't agree with psychiatry.
There was a booth that started to
explain that the loss of p of
scientology.
There was a booth all about l Ron
Hubbard.
There was even a booth where you could
see your own thoughts.
Is the device that you used to do that
looks like an old toy telephone.
After the self guided multimedia tour,
we went up front and asked to take
personality tests.
So I think me and Zee,
I thought that it would be like a 10 to
20 question test,
200 questions.
Some of the questions.
Where do you feel ill at ease in the
company of children?
Do you whistle while you work?
If a 10 year old was acting out of
place,
you would approve corporal punishment.
You find yourself dwelling on past
misfortunes.
You rarely think about past failure
during the type of person who's always
thinking about what you could've done.
Does it sometimes feel that all of
reality is a dream?
Finally a question.
One hundred 92,
they asked the question that they had
been asking over and over in so many
different ways,
are you depressed?
It's very,
very,
very easy to see how if you are
emotionally distressed state bank,
a cow capture you,
big old fucking that on you.
For
someone who is depressed or who just
feels particularly empty for someone
who's tried psychology and psychiatry
and it hasn't for them,
why not adopt the idea that psychiatry
is actually evil?
Sometimes it's easy for us when we're in
a vulnerable position to take the exact
opposite stance of the stance that you
had before when really the answer is not
to flip your ideas 180 degrees,
but only to adjust it a little bit him
either way,
but anyway,
in five minutes the receptionist
returned with the result of our
personality tests.
Here it is.
You can see that it's a line graph
showing where it is.
You are in between the spectrum of
several different traits.
The young scientologist said to me,
now,
sir,
this is not our opinion of you.
This is a scientific analysis of your
opinion of yourself.
So we went over the results and he asked
me a lot of questions which I tried to
answer as honestly as I could,
and a big deal was made.
All the while about how practical
scientology is.
See,
the first step that you take after you
take the personality test is a series of
communication courses.
In those courses,
you're meant to unlearn the ways that
we've learned to imperfectness,
communicate with each other,
and I talked to a few scientologists
there who all said that after those
courses they really learn to open up
themselves to communication and I
believe that it works for them.
Although it may be the clue to why they
all seem a little bit brainwashed.
They're all learning communication in a
way that makes them act the way they do.
You know,
I,
I assume the communications courses and
other courses that you have to take our
very specific.
Anyway,
the next step is purification.
So I asked them what purification was
thinking that it would be just a bunch
of people sitting in a room trying to
think away the toxins.
He said,
actually we have a few large Saunas and
the facility and you sit in them and
sweat out all the toxins and the next
thing after that is the beginning of the
bridge to total freedom.
So here's where I had the question that
I really wanted to ask,
and that was where does the practical
almost utilitarian side of scientology
come into contact with the religious
side?
He couldn't answer that question.
So I had to be taken to a new
scientologists.
So we walked over to another desk and I
sat down and I asked the same question
but a little bit,
frank,
or what do you worship here?
Because Christianity,
for example,
has got the Bible and Jesus and this is
the infallible words of their religion.
Now the second scientologists took the
tack that there is no worship going on
in scientology.
Now I don't know if I really believe
them on that,
but taking him at his word.
I said,
then why do you call yourselves a
religion?
And he said,
well,
you know,
the word religion has been usurped over
the years.
And I said,
yeah,
maybe that's true,
but the religious people have had it for
a good 2000 years,
so let's,
let's just give it to them.
I said to him,
I think you're alienating people by
calling it a religion if all it really
is is a self help community.
Unfortunately that's when I had to leave
because the building was closing and my
neighbors,
he had had to get back to our house.
So what did you think was interesting?
I didn't know about their volunteer
efforts.
She made a big push about religion.
You know,
they know differ that much.
They ask you to be good to other people,
but I'm sure behind closed doors swing
basically segregate people and
always put up walls.
I don't know what I really believe about
scientology.
I don't know what I think goes on in
there.
I don't know where the money comes from.
I don't know any of these things.
To us on the outside looking in.
Scientology is like a frog.
We don't see past the doors,
but I recommend anybody who's interested
to go there because they will give you
certain answers to certain questions and
you can learn at least a little bit
about the mystery that is scientology.
Make your decisions on it for yourself,
but just remember,
give a fake name.